i recognized anyone outside of you yeah
and i was like oh
there's other people yeah and i remember
because i was always i was already uh so
we had four original members there was
holden reviews
um jean who were who was originally
called x disturbed jeans
and uh tristan the glass reflection and
i remember what started it was
tristan one day messaged me out messaged
me out the blue with
the youtube dms being like hey do you
want to talk about this new
anime season and this was before this
was before i'd even started watching
seasonal anime
this is this before this was this was
before the concept of
hey you can watch anime weekly and be
hyped for seasonal anime you know yes
i'm pretty sure you made a joke in one
of your videos where it's like why would
i want to come
over the space of 12 weeks when i could
just come in one big go
that was a joke you made and i
remembered that sorry i completely
forgot about that joke
that's an amazing joke for some reason
that stuck with me and i think that's a
that's a great example i would i would
like to come in one go
no no i think i
thought process is why would i want a
12th of an orgasm when i could just have
one orgasm in one session yeah right
that's such a good joke yeah and so we
so we've we made this podcast which
wasn't even a podcast
um it was it was kind of just a recorded
skype call
and we didn't know where to put it so i
made the suggestion to put it on youtube
because
this was this was before like it was an
audio podcast it wasn't a visual podcast
like this so nobody thought
that putting audio podcasts on youtube
would work and i just i was just like
well we're youtubers so why not
why not put it on youtube right and yeah
it was
i i i don't like saying it like this
because it kind of sounds like it's like
sucky mundick or whatever but
but i would say like potaku was a big
factor in you know shaping the anime the
anime youtube community
of that time no absolutely so i think it
left as somebody who
you know wasn't even interested in being
an anime youtuber i definitely shaped i
think how i
felt about it because at the time i was
listening to podtaku like every week
like i never even i'd never wanted to be
a youtuber never
crossed my mind but definitely when i
got into it i think a lot of the
influences came
from listening to that so i think you
may not have shaped the generation you
were in but you definitely helped shape
the one that came after i mean there's
definitely
you know a reason why even to this day
people who are around in the anime
youtube we get comments about it
back then right yeah people back then
still are like yeah remember pod taco
like
like even people who didn't watch pod
taku knew pod taco yeah i mean it was a
it's it's still a big point in my life
otaku
really really was it
i i think back to portage very fondly
even though it's like ended now and i've
moved on
in my life it had he had a big part of
shaping me as a person and
it's especially because portugal was the
first ever friends i made
that i could talk to anime with yeah you
know i mean that goes all the way back
to the
conversation we had at the start but
holden and jean were literally
the first people i was able to bond over
anime with
and potaku was kind of like my weekly
bi-weekly
kind of session where i could just nerd
over another week just
with your buddies yeah exactly yeah and
apparently a lot of people
looked up to us back then because a lot
of people apparently didn't
also have friends to talk to anime with
that's right
and um and so that really
i feel like that cemented the next era
of
anime youtube before i think i think you
came along
and i think that was that was kind of
the era of youtube where
it was i think it was a last era where
people could just
make content without a monetary
incentive in mind right right right
because everyone
every we we did we did poor taku not
because we were getting paid we weren't
getting paid for it at all
for a lot of it um we we basically made
it because we just wanted two
projects yeah it was a passion it was
kind of like this
but back then this was before we had any
kind of monetization yeah
we we were just we were just four mates
who would just go go on a skype call
um and record the audio and just splice
it together and upload it on youtube and
then i came in when the fat chicks
started rolling
no but like i i don't think it's too
much to say that
you know this podcast included there's a
lot of anime podcasts now right yeah
yeah exactly
big and small and i don't think it'd be
too far to say that
you know pod taco is probably the one
who
probably got the train rolling in that
side of attitude it it kind of amazes me
because like before
this before this came along before trash
taste came along
um you look back to some of the views
and you know
popularity of potaku and it still
basically holds up
almost to a lot of the bigger podcasts
that
came after it i mean there's only a few
podcasts that i can think of
that came after potaku that anime yeah
anime related that were able to you know
do better in it with it in terms of
using
views and stuff and potaka is like six
years old now so that that
kind of that kind of blows my mind you
wanna hear it last from the past sure
warning the following audio may contain
coarse language
and other material that may not be
suitable for a younger audience
viewer discretion is advised that is
screaming
dude there's like maybe a couple of
hundred people watching this right now
who just cream their hair
nostalgia that that intro is like
ingrained in my mind
man that your accent warning is like
it's
so it's so 2012 of course also we may
spoil anything and everything
so you have been warned if you go to my
channel
the very very first video is like a
podcast that looks very reminiscent of
the editing
style of another podcast oh really oh
really yeah it looks very
very similar with the the cubes flashing
up between oh yeah yeah
oh yeah um because yeah who did you edit
all of them
um no so originally it was basically
between me and tristan and holden who
had to
edit most of the podcast and
so we we basically edited the audio so
they would sync up and
we would remove a lot of like when you
have calls on skype
people talking over each other yeah
people are talking over each other and
you have this
really awkward pause where it's where
it's you cut it all up smoothly yeah
yeah
exactly and then we were like we wanted
to make it a bit more visual
so but we couldn't we we couldn't just
film ourselves
next to each other so we kind of just
decided to go with flashing boxes
yeah it works really well yeah yeah and
that was that was our way of just
evolving the podcast
and um i remember after potaku we kind
of added a few more people as well
right i want to ask about that because i
was when as a viewer i was so confused
there was just people
like towards the end would just start
joining in
and then i was like jay taku and i'm
like what is what is going on with all
of this
was jimmy on the podcast yeah jimmy
right people
it was so odd because it just seemed
like people were just recycling in and i
was like wait
this is not what i want i want the boys
i'm on the big fallback you know like as
a viewer i was so confused i don't think
you guys like ever explain any of that
right yeah so i mean
i'd be interested in that well for me it
was because the scheduling just got
super hard
um because like i said we weren't
getting paid for anything so this was
this was just us making time making
making time and we got to a point with
partaku where we were
having a [ __ ] hard time keeping up
with this two-week schedule
so i i wanted to and it had been a while
since potako started so i wanted to
spice things up
um and i wanted to see if there was like
we could get some chemistry with other
people
and that's when i brought on the idea of
jaetaku
and adding more people and making making
a distinct brand of potaku is where we
just talk about
pure whatever we want to talk about it's
kind of like a free-flowing podcast and
jaitaku
is we're going to pick a specific topic
and we're going to stay on top
right right right and that was that was
the kind of
idea of jtaku it was it kind of hit
everything because it
added some new elements to the podcast
and it also
made it so less of a load was on the
original four as well
um but yeah it's it's interesting to
hear what you guys thought about it as a
viewer perspective i think
because i didn't watch every single one
and then
i think i just saw like three j takus
and i was so confused
then i watch it and i'm like who are
half of these people yeah like
yeah it's so strange and i think i think
what
um it was it really worked at first
because jay jay taku
did his job and then it got to the point
when jaitaku
kind of even maybe became the flagship
series because if you look on
if you look on the potaku channel a lot
of the most viewed videos ended up being
jaitaku
origitaki videos like our most viewed
video was
one where we literally just talk about
hentai nice of course
but that that was that was back when
talking about him about it yeah
hentais are like very hush-hush nobody
likes nobody publicly liked hentai on
twitter
or any any [ __ ] like that allow me to
introduce myself
hi but um yeah so jaitaku
kind of became one of the flagship
series um because it just got more views
and
the main like the main the original four
people it just became harder and harder
for us to schedule
um schedule scheduled the original
partaku
yeah yeah podcast um and i think that's
kind of
that's that's kind of what brought like
helped bring portugal to an
end because i feel like i feel like that
era of anitube is defined by the start
of potaku and the end of pataku because
i think the other example
the end of potaku really it
coincidentally coincided with a lot of
the times when
you know joey really rose and people
realized they could do anime content for
money as well
yeah which just wasn't an idea before
then